so tonight's show I had this uh it was a
Bill Clinton Podium and it was a very
well made prop it had a presidential
seal and had a green a red buzzer and I
had you know access to the so I did not
have sex and it ain't it would go like
you know true false true false
so I had this this is great so I I'm
rehearsing it and Jay's over there yeah
and watching and doing a thing and it I
have a foot pedal where I hit the Monica
Lewinsky head would come up behind the
the thing but it's it's beautifully I
mean you see especially on TV it's just
you know true false and it builds it's
like I did not have sex this is true and
all sudden I'd hit the pedal and this
head would come up and I go not now I go
back to the speech and so it like Beyond
kills you know this is you know just a
rehearsal with this Nitros there's eight
camera guys and four guys and one lady
with a clipboard saying you can't do
anything that you just did
so standards and practices lady hated me
so
kills and I look over and Chase side
yeah he's laughing oh guys that's going
to be the closers just so you know and
she walks over and she's like
everything's everything was fine except
and it was weird everything was fine I
did like I don't know I mousetrap to
catch game ice it had like a little
mirror ball and a mouse trap and she's
like I guess the gay mousetrap's okay
I'm like well why wouldn't it be she's
like
as it happens you know Podium you know
his Podium is fine I said
all right that was in question but the
podium with a blow job was fine right so
I'm like I can't believe this I go back
to my dress room I'm all excited this is
going to be the best set I've ever done
in The Tonight Show the ending is just
it's so timely I mean it just happened
the Monica lewinsk so she comes walking
in I mean like five minutes I'm already
dressed makeup on you ever see me with
makeup no it looks so good no so I'm all
ready to go and and she says oh
real quickly you can't you can't you
can't you can't use your hand
to put her head back down
oh and I'm like what's that she's like
yeah you can't use your hand I said
well what do I do then she goes it can't
go back down it can come up but you
can't well the joke would get a laugh
that but the big laugh was when I was so
not now and go back to the aim so I I
I'm like well I I don't know so
she said just don't use your hand
don't use your so I go up and I'm it's
it's the moment I'm there [__]
killing that's exactly what I did
no he used my elbow no I said I did not
have sex and you know did Oak it's still
killed but boy they go to commercial
break and my the crowd's going nuts I
sit down and Tracy comes over that oh my
God that was your best set ever and my
God it's just you never know the numbers
people are you know this point stayed at
4.8 it went up to 5.2 when you when you
came on know what that means
yeah there's like they um they know
every number within seconds of people
watching the The Tonight Show so when
the comment comes on they leave so they
stayed for me so she said this is great
you know everyone stayed and the numbers
went up and they're it's you you're a
genius and I said I'm like that was that
was good now James like that was really
great that's your best friend ever and
then all of a sudden oh [__] here comes
leave the clipboard she's like I told
you I said I'd use my hand
she's like we're gonna have to edit it
I'm like no
she's like yeah I told you not you so I
think I think they it went from you know
they and they just they cut it the the
last you know my big thing but yeah so
they still brought me back but I always
say in the show they threw me off
forever but they they had me back but
then she's like every time I tell you
something you have to listen to me oh my
God I said oh you do I didn't know that
[Music]